so you have these neurotransmitters
coming into the synapse and what happens
with them the receptors have to do with
it what happens the Sacrament Institute
is conceived of being across campus
interdisciplinary neuroscience Research
Institute and we consider our mission to
include engaging with the public and
increasing people's awareness about
brain and brain science and to do that
we have a number of programs that
interface with the public and one of
them is the Brainiac program this is our
signature program for high school
students in which we admit about 14 or
more students each year to train them in
neuroscience concepts how a lab works we
give them safety training they learn a
little bit about the campus and about
science in general coming into the lab I
didn't really know what to expect
working with people older than you more
educated than you I was a bit nervous
and then coming here and having everyone
so willing to help and so cooperative it
was really eye-opening and inspiring to
see like people so willing to help you
out I've never really knew a career I
wanted to pursue so when I heard about
research I wanted to like sort of
explore to see if I would like it and it
turns out that I really do like it I've
been working with different proteins to
see how they behave like compared to
other proteins that they already found
before so it's really cool to see
something that nobody else has seen like
it's just research that I've been doing
and it's all new research is very much
an art you know a lot of people have a
misconception about science then if you
memorize a lot of facts and you organize
them together well that you'll be a good
scientist right that's how high schools
teach science it's our schools tend to
teach science but science is an art it's
very much a creative process where you
imagine how things are moving you make a
hypothesis then you test it and because
it's such an art it's important to have
diverse opinions so you know the
students that we have in our lab
how it you know I want their input I
want them to put their paint strokes on
the other painting because their input
into this this movement is critical when
I first met him he told me what his lab
was about and he did it with a drawing
and it's like a you don't really expect
that from a doctor like to draw
something in front of you and make it
like put into terms were a kid would
understand it so it was like an
experience I've really cherished I think
it's absolutely essential for me to open
up the lab first of all it gives me
great pleasure but second of all because
it recapitulates my own life there was
no one less likely to do science than I
I didn't know what the lab was like a
social environment you and me
interacting talking about things
designing simple experiments that you
then do with your own hands you see the
results of your own ideas are the ideas
right are the ideas wrong it's a
wonderful experience this is what I
think Brainiac is about I think it's to
bring kids into environment where they
see the intellectual excitement the
social engagement that goes on do you
essentially see the little scientists in
these students growing at the very
beginning they think I can't do this I'm
not smart enough this is too hard and
many of them by the end actually want to
stay in the lab we try to prepare them
for their summer experience from the
very practical things like pipetting
making measurements making solutions to
more theoretical things like what is a
neuron I want to become a neuro surgeon
and Brainiac has just educated me about
the parts of the brain and I just know
more about neurology and it's helped me
a lot one of the nice things about this
program is it allows you know the
students to learn a lot about research
but it actually helps me because she's
doing valuable work so Cheyenne was
identifying the or creating
three-dimensional representations of the
areas of the brain that were removed by
neurosurgeons in some sense she was
doing a lot of the same kind
the things that any graduate student
might actually be doing in this lab I
think it's important to realize that the
function of university makes the
teaching and research it inseparable
this is another generation of colleagues
that we're bringing in to help the work
and as they work they learn now with the
Zukerman mine brain behavior initiative
we're going to be in Manhattanville
we're going to be sort of opening
ourselves up so we can really have a
useful in fact in the community and try
to get young people interested in some
of the most exciting scientific
questions of our time